Hello, welcome to Smart List. I am Jason Bateman, one of the less smart hosts. Even less smart is Will Arnett and truly dumb is Sean Hayes. We each have invited, well, one of us invites a guest per week. The other two don't know who that person is. Some of it's going to be funny. Hopefully you won't cry and hopefully you learn a little something. So let's get started Well, here's the sad part you have chumma wumba on your thing ready to go and it's not a joke. No, it's a ringtone. He's probably getting a call, I think. I've been going so Chumbawumba heavy lately on the, I keep going like mid conversation, Alessandro will say something and I'll just go, you know, the thing about me is I get knocked down. But I get up again and she's like, but between that and my 10 year love affair with figuring
你好，欢迎来到《Smart List》。我是杰森·贝特曼，是几位不太聪明的播客主持人之一。威尔·阿奈特更不聪明，而肖恩·海耶斯则是真的笨。我们每个人都邀请了——好吧，是我们中的一个人每周邀请一位嘉宾。另外两个人不知道嘉宾是谁。其中一些内容会很有趣。希望你不会哭，也希望你能学到一点东西。那么我们开始吧。好吧，这里有个悲伤的部分，你的设备里准备好了Chumbawamba的歌，而且这不是开玩笑。不，那是铃声。我想他可能接到电话了。我最近一直在听Chumbawamba，我总是聊着聊着，亚历山德罗会说些什么，我就直接接上一句，你知道，关于我，我会被击倒。但我会再次站起来，她就像是，但在这之间，还有我那10年对弄清楚
out who let the dogs out. Right. But what about that, that, that, what's the, that crap ass band that, well actually I've never heard their music, but their goddamn name. Bon Iver. Bon Iver. Yeah. Bon Iver.
到底是谁把狗放出来的热爱。没错。但那又怎样，那个，那个，那个，那个烂乐队，虽然我从来没听过他们的音乐，但他们那该死的名字。Bon Iver。Bon Iver。是的。Bon Iver。
First of all, Bon Iver is a great band. So is it, hang on, B-O-N-E-Y and then V-A-R or something like that? Yeah, that's what it is. You fucking idiot. What's a bony bear? Like, would there be like a fat bear? It's... Wait, what song are they singing? What is it? It's B-O-N and then space I-V-E-R. Oh, he likes it because it's French and he's like, I can speak French. D-O-N and then space I-V-E-R. Oh, he likes it because it's French and he's like,
首先，Bon Iver是个很棒的乐队。等等，是B-O-N-E-Y然后是V-A-R之类的吗？是的，就是那样。你这个蠢货。什么叫“骨头熊”？就像，会有一只胖熊吗？它是……等等，他们在唱什么歌？是什么？是B-O-N然后空格I-V-E-R。哦，他喜欢它是因为它是法语，他就像是，我会说法语。D-O-N然后空格I-V-E-R。哦，他喜欢它是因为它是法语，他就像是，
I can speak French. It's not French, he's from fucking Wisconsin and it's this guy, Justin Vernon and my friend Chris Messina who works with the band and like. Oh, then they're great. I don't know where our guest is, but I guarantee you that they like Bon Iver. I have this feeling that they do.
我会说法语。那不是法语，他是个来自威斯康星州的家伙，是这个叫贾斯汀·弗农的人，还有和我一起工作的我朋友克里斯·梅西纳，就像。哦，那他们很棒。我不知道我们的嘉宾在哪里，但我保证他们肯定喜欢Bon Iver。我有种预感他们会喜欢。
How much you wanna bet? How much you wanna bet? You wanna do a real bet? Wait, I want. 100 Canadian dollars. Sean, you know who this is, so you can't chime in. 100 Canadian dollars right now. Great, so it's a five dollar bet?
你想赌多少？你想赌多少？你想来个真正的赌注吗？等等，我想。100加元。肖恩，你知道这是谁，所以你不能插嘴。现在就赌100加元。太好了，所以这是个五美元的赌注？
Is that what you're saying? You know what, dude, that's so insulting. That's so insulting to me and to all my Canadian brethren who I'm gonna put your address online. Oh, right on, right on. Well, just give her. Wait, can I tell you guys something that Scotty and I were watching?
你是这个意思吗？你知道吗，伙计，这太侮辱人了。这对我和我所有的加拿大同胞来说太侮辱人了，我要把你地址发到网上。哦，太棒了，太棒了。好吧，那就给吧。等等，我能告诉你们一件事吗，我和斯科蒂在看什么？
Hey, were you just changing your diaper? What did you just pull out from your pants? Why do you wear a pashmina as a diaper? Because it was cold and now it's hot. I was watching Field of Dreams last night. I've never seen the movie. Okay, hold for applause? What are you doing?
嘿，你刚才是在换尿布吗？你刚才从裤子里掏出了什么？你为什么要穿一条羊绒披肩当尿布？因为刚才冷，现在热了。我昨晚在看《梦幻之地》。我从来没看过这部电影。好吧，停下来鼓掌？你在干什么？
Okay. No, it was really? What are you doing? Okay. No, it was really good, but I mean, it's kind of a long way to go to tell a story about playing catch with your dad, but I get it. It was sweet, you know, Scottie's like, you know, these people won Academy Awards, I don't know, they were nominated or something. And then we started having this conversation
好吧。不，它真的？你在干什么？好吧。不，它真的很棒，但我的意思是，讲一个关于和你爸爸玩传接球的故事，这铺垫也太长了，但我懂了。这很温馨，你知道，斯科蒂说，你知道，这些人赢过奥斯卡奖，我不知道，他们被提名过还是什么的。然后我们开始进行这个对话
about who would we conjure up from the past that like, if you could, who would that be for you guys? Who would it be if- Hey, listen, Jason played catch with his dad at home, and by his dad I mean the security guy at Fox, and by catch I mean smoking butts behind stage five. But look. Yeah.
关于我们会从过去召唤谁，如果可以的话，对你们来说会是谁？如果会是——嘿，听着，杰森在家里和他爸爸玩传接球，我说的爸爸是指福克斯的保安，我说的传接球是指在五号摄影棚后面抽烟。但你看。是的。
Oh God, all right well, we'll get to that later. Sean, who are you so rudely keeping waiting? On our little podcast today, we have a gorgeous woman inside and out, who we all know, we're all friends with, and we all love. She is a light, guys. Her lineage is filled with all kinds of famous people.
哦天哪，好吧，我们稍后再谈这个。肖恩，你这么粗鲁地让谁在等？在我们今天的小播客里，我们有一位由内而外都很美的女士，我们都认识，我们都是朋友，我们都爱她。她是个发光体，伙计们。她的血统里充满了各种各样有名的人。
I'm trying to build even the slightest bit of anticipation because you're going to know who it is. Let me try with this one, this random thing. She graduated college with a degree in photography. Can you guess who that is? Annie Leibowitz. That's it. She's a staple in the history of American comedy,
我正试图建立哪怕一点点的期待感，因为你肯定会知道她是谁。让我试试这个，这个随机的东西。她大学毕业时拿的是摄影学位。你能猜到那是谁吗？安妮·莱博维茨。就是她。她是美国喜剧史上的中流砥柱，
will be remembered forever for her many contributions in film and television. She's trending so goddamn hard on social media right now because of her impression of Kamala Harris. It's Maya Rudolph! No way! What? Stacks and the something and the something.
她因在电影和电视方面的诸多贡献而被永远铭记。她现在在社交媒体上火得一塌糊涂，因为她模仿了卡玛拉·哈里斯。是玛雅·鲁道夫！不会吧！什么？Stacks和那个什么还有那个什么。
Come on, Look at this! Oh, pop the cork! Pop the cork! Oh my god. I was trying to sing Bon Iver. In the stacks, in the something, in the something, in the something. Okay, so wait. Right? How good is Bon Iver? Bon Iver is great. I listened to the whole thing and I felt bad for Bateman.
来吧，看这个！哦，开香槟！开香槟！哦天哪。我刚才在试着唱Bon Iver。在堆栈里，在那个什么里，在那个什么里，在那个什么里。好吧，等等。对吧？Bon Iver有多好？Bon Iver很棒。我听了整张专辑，我为贝特曼感到难过。
Because he sounded old. I know, didn't he? And felt bad for Bateman because he sounded old I know identity and now you look at him. He looks old. That's fucked up So they're they're less gross than the name. They're a person I think right isn't it? Isn't it a person? It's Justin Vernon pretty much and he has other guys who are in the band as well Sean Carey who plays but they're good friends of mine. They're great guys and they make great music. Hi Maya Rudolph. Hi Maya Rudolph. Hi guys. Thanks for being here. Sorry for the mood lighting. I'm in a cave it's the only quiet place at my house. No I was gonna say thank you for the mood lighting. I'm gonna join you. It's a wank fest. Welcome to my jackshack. Yeah he was talking about that the other day, how he, you bounced that name off of
因为他听起来很老。我知道，不是吗？我为贝特曼感到难过，因为他听起来很老。我知道，身份，现在你看着他。他看起来很老。这太糟糕了。所以他们比那个名字没那么恶心。他们是一个人，我想，对吧？不是吗？是一个人吗？基本上就是贾斯汀·弗农，他还有其他乐队成员，肖恩·凯里也参与演奏，但他们是我很好的朋友。他们是很棒的家伙，他们做很棒的音乐。嗨，玛雅·鲁道夫。嗨，玛雅·鲁道夫。嗨，伙计们。谢谢你们邀请我。抱歉这灯光氛围，我在一个洞穴里，这是我家唯一安静的地方。不，我本来想说谢谢你的灯光氛围。我要加入你。这简直是个手淫派对。欢迎来到我的“打手枪小屋”。是的，他前几天还在说这个，他怎么，你把那个名字抛给了
you. Oh my God. Do you remember I used to say that to you? Did you finally build your Jack Shack? He's in it right now. Look at him. I can see it. That's why he's got a smile on his face.
你。哦天哪。你还记得我以前那样对你说吗？你终于建好你的“打手枪小屋”了吗？他现在就在里面。看他。我能看到。这就是他脸上带着微笑的原因。
The guru. And no pantalones. Now, Maya, the reason you're looking for quiet is because there are six, 17 kids? 18 kids over there, right? 18, Jason. Good for you. 18. The reason you're looking for quiet is because there are six, 17 kids? 18 kids over there, right? 18, Jason. Good for you. 18.
大师。而且没穿裤子。现在，玛雅，你寻找安静的原因是因为有六个，17个孩子？那边有18个孩子，对吧？18个，杰森。为你感到高兴。18个。你寻找安静的原因是因为有六个，17个孩子？那边有18个孩子，对吧？18个，杰森。为你感到高兴。18个。
I like to pop them out. There is nothing elastic about my lower region. Nothing. It's basically like when you get a grocery bag and something has spilled and then everything just falls out of the bottom. So the bottom got too saturated and now it's useless to you. So kids are falling out daily. Falling out daily.
我喜欢把他们生出来。我的下半身一点弹性都没有。一点都没有。基本上就像你拿个购物袋，东西洒了，然后所有东西都从底部掉出来一样。所以底部太饱和了，现在对你没用了。所以孩子每天都在掉出来。每天都在掉出来。
Do your kids love that description of how they came into the world? My son, well my son thinks that he came out of my butt because he saw like a birth video. So we like to keep it that way. My son said the other day, little Abel said the other day, he was in the backseat, Archie and I were arguing about the genesis of, this is terrible parenting, of Grand Theft Auto games and which one came first in GTA V.
你的孩子喜欢这种关于他们如何来到这个世界的描述吗？我儿子，嗯，我儿子认为他是从我屁股里出来的，因为他看过那种出生视频。所以我们喜欢保持这种说法。我儿子前几天说，小阿贝尔前几天说，他在后座，阿奇和我正在争论关于起源，这是糟糕的育儿，关于《侠盗猎车手》游戏，哪一个先出的，GTA V。
And Abel's in the back saying, hey real quick could you Wikipedia? And he cuts me off and he goes how babies are made? You got it. He's got that on his favorites. It's just a one button. You know Maya your husband did describe having a bunch of kids running around the house. He says it's so great, he's a better word, it's like having a fire burning in each room. It's all warm and cozy. He said that? He said that?
阿贝尔在后面说，嘿，快点，你能查一下维基百科吗？他打断我说，婴儿是怎么制造的？你懂的。他把那个放在收藏夹里了。就是一个按钮。你知道玛雅，你丈夫确实描述过家里有一堆孩子跑来跑去。他说这太棒了，他有个更好的词，就像每个房间都烧着火。既温暖又舒适。他这么说了？他这么说了？
Well, he's a bit of a poet. I thought he was gonna tell the Jim Gaffigan joke about how it's like, because Jim Gaffigan has five, right? And I think his joke was having a fifth kid is like swimming in a pool and you're drowning and someone hands you a baby. and you're drowning and someone hands you a baby. It's a bit overwhelming.
嗯，他有点诗人气质。我以为他要讲吉姆·加菲根那个关于它是什么的笑话，因为吉姆·加菲根有五个，对吧？我想他的笑话是，生第五个孩子就像在游泳池里游泳，你快淹死了，然后有人递给你一个婴儿。你快淹死了，然后有人递给你一个婴儿。这有点让人不知所措。
I have to say that being in quarantine with four kids is great because I would be very depressed if I was not very busy. It would be a lot more quiet and depressing. Look at Sean. Yeah, look at Sean. I just got up. Sean is so low right now, he'd have to rally to die.
我不得不说，在隔离期间带着四个孩子很棒，因为如果我不忙的话，我会非常沮丧。那会安静得多，也压抑得多。看看肖恩。是的，看看肖恩。我刚起床。肖恩现在状态太低迷了，他得振作起来才能去死。
That's how low. How many books is your computer on right now? Is your computer on? My computer is actually on a stand right now. But I like to say the books behind me on the shelf, I've read every single one of those jackets. Nice. Oh, boy.
就是那么低迷。你的电脑现在垫着几本书？你的电脑在上面吗？我的电脑现在其实在一个支架上。但我喜欢说我身后架子上的书，那些书皮我每一本都读过。不错。哦，天哪。
Who do you say that to, to Scotty or? I say to anybody who'll listen. He says it to all the living members of Chumbawamba. Maya, are those kids old enough to help out around the house or are they just asking you to help them find things to do? Because that is the only reason Jason had children. Right, I just, I can't keep them entertained.
你是对谁说的，对斯科蒂还是？我对任何愿意听的人说。他对Chumbawamba所有在世的成员都这么说。玛雅，那些孩子大到可以帮忙做家务了吗，还是他们只是让你帮他们找事情做？因为那是杰森生孩子的唯一原因。没错，我只是，我无法让他们保持娱乐。
Do you have any teenagers yet? Yeah, I got a 13-year-old and an 8-year-old. The problem with the teen part is I feel really badly for them because they want to be social, but then I don't want them to be on their fucking devices all day long. But then you got to talk to them. If they're off the device, then you have to talk to them. It's killing me.
你有青少年了吗？是的，我有一个13岁的和一个8岁的。青少年部分的问题是，我真的为他们感到难过，因为他们想社交，但我又不想让他们整天盯着该死的设备。但你又得和他们说话。如果他们不看设备，你就得和他们说话。这快把我逼疯了。
And I also feel like. Lesser the two evils is just a thicker data plan, right? Yeah. Oh, I thought you meant dad plan, yeah. Let's let Bateman keep talking, let him hang himself. Keep going, dude, what is it? So one teenager or two teenagers?
而且我也觉得。两害相权取其轻，就是更厚的数据套餐，对吧？是的。哦，我以为你说的是“爸爸套餐”，是的。让贝特曼继续说，让他自掘坟墓。继续，伙计，是什么？所以是一个青少年还是两个青少年？
I have one teenager, she's 14. The others are? I have one teenager, she's 14. The others are? I have no idea. No, 10, nine, and seven. Almost 11, nine, and seven. Is the 14-year-old a nightmare? Has she found her sass yet at 14? No, she's not a nightmare, she's the opposite. So I feel really bad,
我有一个青少年，她14岁。其他的呢？我有一个青少年，她14岁。其他的呢？我不知道。不，10岁、9岁和7岁。快11岁、9岁和7岁。那个14岁的孩子是噩梦吗？她在14岁时找到她的叛逆期了吗？不，她不是噩梦，她正好相反。所以我感到很抱歉，
because she's a nice person. That's Pearl, right? Yeah. I love her. Don't show off, Sean. Oh. You know, we all have Google. Sean is godparent to all of my children. Is that true? No. Yeah, and like my dad, I've never shown up for them.
因为她是个好人。那是珀尔，对吧？是的。我爱她。别炫耀了，肖恩。哦。你知道，我们都有谷歌。肖恩是我所有孩子的教父。那是真的吗？不。是的，就像我爸爸一样，我从来没为他们出现过。
Oh. Are you guys godparents to anybody? No. I am. I don't even, I don't know what that means. What does it mean? Yeah, I don't either, because I think I failed.
哦。你们是任何人的教父吗？不。我是。我甚至，我不知道那意味着什么。那意味着什么？是的，我也不知道，因为我想我失败了。
Well, we are, we're actually very active godparents, me and Scotty, to Jonah and Sammy, Carrie Aisley's children. You are? Yeah. And so, and we're very active, and legally, it's just somebody in the highly unlikely and hopeful never happening case,
嗯，我们是，我们其实是非常活跃的教父，我和斯科蒂，是乔纳和萨米，凯莉·艾斯利的孩子的教父。你们是？是的。而且，我们非常活跃，从法律上讲，这只是在极不可能且希望永远不会发生的情况下，
where something happens to them, we are the legal guardians. Right. I don't think that's always the case. It's not a religious thing? No, it used to be a religious thing, and I think now it's much more of a just sort of a custom thing that you do. And, babe, listen, should we be godparents to each other's kids just out of safety?
如果他们出了什么事，我们是法定监护人。没错。我不认为情况总是这样。这不是宗教事务吗？不，过去是宗教事务，我想现在更多只是一种你做的习俗。而且，宝贝，听着，我们应该为了安全起见互为对方孩子的教父吗？
No, no, no, we're all set. I'm good. He's good. You want to send over the paperwork? He's good. Yeah, yeah, no, Amanda's got it handled, bro. We're all good. How about a question for Maya?
不，不，不，我们都准备好了。我很好。他很好。你想把文书工作发过来吗？他很好。是的，是的，不，阿曼达处理好了，兄弟。我们都很好。给玛雅提个问题怎么样？
You don't even know what's for dinner. Maya's actually the godparent to Scotty. I am. Does she powder and swaddle him? Yes, I do. I don't even know what's for dinner. Maya's actually the godparent to Scotty. I am. Does she powder and swaddle him? Yes, I do. Maya, I have to say a couple things. One is. I love you too.
你甚至不知道晚饭吃什么。玛雅其实是斯科蒂的教父。我是。她给他擦粉和裹襁褓吗？是的，我做。我甚至不知道晚饭吃什么。玛雅其实是斯科蒂的教父。我是。她给他擦粉和裹襁褓吗？是的，我做。玛雅，我必须说几件事。第一是。我也爱你。
I do, I really do love you and I miss you and I feel like I never see you. I know, I love you too. I don't ever see you. I know, it's wrong. But first of all, I have to say the thing that we all know but not everybody knows, which is that your mom is Minnie Ripperton, who sang Love and You.
我确实，我真的爱你，我想你，我觉得我从来没见过你。我知道，我也爱你。我从来没见过你。我知道，这不对。但首先，我必须说那件我们都知道但不是每个人都知道的事，那就是你的妈妈是明妮·里珀顿，她唱了《Love and You》。
I was so surprised that you threw in the lineage thing. These dudes are like, who, what? Yeah, I don't even know Bon Iberes. Oh, come on. Your grandfather owned all the Wendy's in like Florida or something? Yes, I've been to Florida. Isn't that crazy?
我很惊讶你提到了血统的事。这些家伙就像是，谁，什么？是的，我甚至不知道Bon Iver。哦，得了吧。你祖父拥有佛罗里达州所有的温迪汉堡店还是什么的？是的，我去过佛罗里达。那不是很疯狂吗？
Hang on. Sidney Rudolph. Free burgers for life or? So supposedly my grandfather and his brother were these big time business boys back in the day and he came up with this idea for a company called Trip Charge and where it was like you could get a card
等等。西德尼·鲁道夫。终身免费汉堡还是？所以据说是我的祖父和他的兄弟在那个年代是这些大人物，他想出了一个叫“Trip Charge”的公司的点子，在那里就像你可以拿一张卡，
and charge it when you were on a trip. This was before the credit card was invented. And it was like you could get a card and charge it when you were on a trip. This was before the credit card was invented. And it was such a great idea that he sold the idea to Diners Club. Way to go, Sid Rudolph. Is Diners Club still around? I don't know, but I guess he straight up gave him the idea for the credit card. So Diners Club was just for restaurants? Is that what it was? That's a great question. I don't know.
当你旅行时刷卡。这在信用卡发明之前。就像你可以拿一张卡，当你旅行时刷卡。这在信用卡发明之前。这是一个如此伟大的点子，他把这个点子卖给了大来卡。干得好，西德·鲁道夫。大来卡还在吗？我不知道，但我猜他直接把信用卡的点子给了他们。所以大来卡只是为了餐馆？是这样吗？这是个好问题。我不知道。
I don't know if it was like a traveler's check situation for going out. I remember those, traveler's checks. Traveler's checks. Cart Blanche, remember Cart Blanche was a thing for a minute? What was Cart Blanche? It's similar, it's like diners club. I thought it was like, oh, Cart Blanche,
我不知道它是不是像旅行支票那样的情况。我记得那些，旅行支票。旅行支票。Cart Blanche，记得Cart Blanche曾经流行过一阵子吗？什么是Cart Blanche？它很相似，就像大来卡。我以为它是，哦，Cart Blanche，
and you just say it. I like, speaking of the Rudolphs, how is your dad? He's good, are you asking about my sweet dad? Isn't my dad the best? He's so sweet. He's that guy my whole life that people ask me about I just got another one today I'm at look at look at Bateman Bateman's like I don't know your dad What why don't I get to meet your dad? Her dad is such a cool guy and you would be well-served This is like the Boney Veer thing. You would be well-served to take that scowl off your face. That's my rest face now
你只要说出来就行。我喜欢，说到鲁道夫一家，你爸爸怎么样？他很好，你在问我亲爱的爸爸吗？我爸爸不是最棒的吗？他太贴心了。他是我一生中人们一直问我的那个人，我今天又遇到了一个，看，看贝特曼，贝特曼就像，我不认识你爸爸。为什么我没能见到你爸爸？她爸爸是个很酷的人，你会受益匪浅。这就像Bon Iver那件事。你会受益匪浅，把那副愁容从脸上拿掉。那是我的休息脸。
I have a heavy brow. I need a lift But I am talking a lot about this I need a lift. But I am talking a lot about this. I constantly look like I'm I've just said what did you say? Yeah. That's my rest face. Yeah. Mine too. Wait are you just coming to terms with this? Just to get to regular I have to I have to pretend I've just said oh I see. Right. That's what I have. That lifts things up to where center is. I think it's from years of being funny and years of emoting,
我的眉毛很重。我需要提拉。但我说了很多关于这个，我需要提拉。但我说了很多关于这个。我看起来总是像我刚说了，你说什么？是的。那是我的休息脸。是的。我也是。等等，你刚接受这个事实吗？为了达到正常状态，我必须假装我刚说了，哦，我明白了。没错。我就是这样。那把东西提到了中心位置。我想这是多年来搞笑和多年来表达情绪的结果，
and now your skin is relaxing into itself. I have developed really gnarly eye bags, and I think it's from years of rubber face. Me too, Maya. Maybe you and I can find a doctor that can just cinch us up in all the places. As eyes and vaginas. Yeah.
现在你的皮肤正在放松。我长出了非常难看的眼袋，我想这是多年来“橡胶脸”的结果。我也是，玛雅。也许你和我可以找个医生，把我们所有的地方都拉紧。眼睛和阴道。是的。
There's probably somebody in the valley somewhere. They're kind of similar. They're similar areas. Get your eyes and vaginas done here. That's like shampoo and shampoo. Shampoo and shampoo. Who knows, Ali. Shampoo and shampoo.
山谷里可能某处有个人。它们有点相似。它们是相似的区域。在这里做你的眼睛和阴道手术。那就像洗发水和洗发水。洗发水和洗发水。谁知道呢，阿里。洗发水和洗发水。
Shampoo and in the back you get shampoo. Here's a very dark, dark story. Oh, Ali. But hang on, before you get into this, I do want to say this. That I went on a date with Ali. You went on a date with Ali? Wait, this is. What do you mean?
洗发水，后面你再洗一次。这是一个非常黑暗，黑暗的故事。哦，阿里。但等等，在你进入这个之前，我确实想说这个。我和阿里约会过。你和阿里约会过？等等，这是。你是什么意思？
I went on a date with Ali in New York and he took me to see Puppetry of the Penis. Do you remember that show? Wait, yes, I saw it in England. It was terrible. Wait, Ali, who's Ali? Ali Farnakian. Ali Farnakian is a funny guy.
我在纽约和阿里约会过，他带我去看《阴茎木偶戏》。你还记得那个节目吗？等等，是的，我在英国看过。太糟糕了。等等，阿里，谁是阿里？阿里·法纳基安。阿里·法纳基安是个有趣的家伙。
He's the guy who came up with Shampooch and Shampooch, no married with a couple kids. And we used to pass- And both named Shampooch and Shampooch. Shampooch, and we used to pass Puppetry of the Penis all the time on the way home on Seventh Avenue. And then we used to also, Amy and I used to always pass and we'd always say to each other,
他是想出“Shampooch”和“Shampooch”的那个家伙，不，结婚了，有几个孩子。我们过去常常经过——而且都叫“Shampooch”和“Shampooch”。Shampooch，我们过去常常在回家的路上经过《阴茎木偶戏》，在第七大道。然后我们过去也，艾米和我过去总是经过，我们总是对彼此说，
my favorite title for a play over was, I love you, you're perfect, now change. Yeah. Oh my God. I saw Puppetry of the Pen penis. I thought it was gonna be like this brilliant thing. It was just guys playing with dicks on stage. It was so painful and awful looking. A lot of stretching of skin. Yeah. Wait, so there was actual frontal nudity all the way through it? Yeah. Really? Are they cut or uncut? They were, well they're Australian, so. Yeah. So uncut. Uncut, they're Australian. So yeah, so one got uncut so snutters Wait what it's a snutter right if it's called a snutter. I believe so
我最喜欢的剧名是，《我爱你，你很完美，现在改变》。是的。哦天哪。我看了《阴茎木偶戏》。我以为那会是什么精彩的东西。那只是舞台上几个家伙在玩弄阴茎。看起来太痛苦和可怕了。皮肤拉伸了很多。是的。等等，所以全程都有真正的正面全裸？是的。真的吗？他们是割了还是没割？他们是，嗯，他们是澳大利亚人，所以。是的。所以没割。没割，他们是澳大利亚人。所以是的，所以一个没割，所以“snutters”。等等，什么，那是“snutter”，对吧，如果它叫“snutter”。我想是的。
I've never still has its little turtleneck. I'm a disgusting foul person and I've never heard that term What about aardvark we school more? Yeah, sure aardvark is standard I love the idea that Bateman goes in to get a facelift and the doctor says, no, just do the surprise face more. Yeah, and could you take care of my snuts? How many snutters do you have? I've got three penises. Sean, I cut you off 10 minutes ago.
我从来没，它还有它的小高领。我是一个恶心、肮脏的人，我从来没听过那个词。那“食蚁兽”呢，我们学校更多？是的，当然，食蚁兽是标准的。我喜欢贝特曼去拉皮，医生说，不，多做点惊讶的表情。是的，你能处理我的“snutters”吗？你有几个“snutters”？我有三个阴茎。肖恩，我10分钟前就打断你了。
You cut me off 10 years ago, but that's okay. Hi-oh. No, no, I was just gonna tell a story about my mom who passed away like two or three years ago, God rest her soul, best mom in the whole wide world, darkest sense of humor, that's why it's okay to tell this story, she would even laugh at this. And so when she was two years old, she had cancer
你10年前就打断我了，但没关系。嗨。不，不，我只是想讲一个关于我妈妈的故事，她两三年前去世了，上帝保佑她的灵魂，世界上最好的妈妈，最黑暗的幽默感，这就是为什么讲这个故事没关系，她甚至会嘲笑这个。所以当她两岁时，她得了癌症，
and they removed her eye, the entire eye out of her socket. I knew that. And it wasn't until she passed away that I found her old medical records from when she was a kid and realized and learned that they took skin It wasn't until she passed away that I found her old medical records from when she was a kid and Realized and learned that they took skin from around her vagina to reshape her eye socket Which was kind of astonishing back then but you know I'd share the story with a friend of mine And he said wait a minute you're just telling me this now the whole time. I knew her I could have fucked her in the eye I thought you were gonna say I thought you were gonna say to her,
他们切除了她的眼睛，整个眼球从眼眶里取出来。我知道那个。直到她去世，我才找到她小时候的旧医疗记录，意识到并了解到他们取了她阴道周围的皮肤来重塑她的眼眶，这在当时有点令人震惊，但你知道，我把这个故事分享给我的一个朋友，他说，等等，你现在才告诉我这个？我认识她的整个期间，我本可以在她眼睛里操她。我以为你要说，我以为你要说，
everybody looked like a cunt. Oh my god. It's brilliant. That's better than everything I was working on. I had tear duct stuff and yeah. Oh my god. Okay. Maya, I'm so sorry.
每个人看起来都像个阴道。哦天哪。太精彩了。那比我正在做的所有事情都好。我有泪管的东西，是的。哦天哪。好吧。玛雅，我很抱歉。
This is an X-rated show, right? Yeah, no, we're gonna cut that out. So listen... God, that's really funny. God, that's really funny. So I want to ask you, seriously, back to Minnie, your mom. Your dad produced that record from your mom, right? Yeah, they wrote a bunch of songs together and stuff.
这是X级节目，对吧？是的，不，我们要把它剪掉。所以听着……天哪，那真的很有趣。天哪，那真的很有趣。所以我认真地想问你，回到明妮，你妈妈身上。你爸爸制作了你妈妈的那张唱片，对吧？是的，他们一起写了很多歌之类的。
So, another common question, I'm sorry, but I think you and your... Did I get laid? Yes, I did. Did I get laid? Did I get laid? But did you, because you have a great singing voice too. Did you ever want to do albums and all that
所以，另一个常见的问题，我很抱歉，但我认为你和你的……我上床了吗？是的，我上了。我上床了吗？我上床了吗？但你呢，因为你也有很好的歌喉。你有没有想过做专辑之类的，
and sing and perform like that? I think the performing part, yes, but the singing part I knew very early on that I did not have the vocal range of my mother. Well, because you were surrounded by music the whole time. Yeah, musical, but I don't have that kind of a voice. I mean, when the standard is like a seven octave range, you're sort of like, I'm good, but I like making music.
像那样唱歌和表演？我想表演部分，是的，但唱歌部分我早就知道我没有我母亲的音域。嗯，因为你一直被音乐包围着。是的，音乐，但我没有那种声音。我的意思是，当标准是七个八度音阶时，你就像是，我还可以，但我喜欢做音乐。
I do like making music. I think now that I'm almost 50, I'll probably start publicly making music now that I'm not as afraid as I used to be How does one start is it like you start with jingles or? Yeah, you know like you write songs about lettuce you're like, huh? Here we come light and free Gold and crispy the way it should be Crispy too. That's right Bateman. Swallow it down. From yourself.
我确实喜欢做音乐。我想现在我快50岁了，我可能会开始公开做音乐，因为我现在不像以前那么害怕了。一个人怎么开始，是像从广告歌开始吗？是的，你知道，就像你写关于生菜的歌，你就像，哈？我们来了，轻盈自由，金黄酥脆，就该这样。酥脆也是。没错，贝特曼。吞下去。从你自己那里。
Bateman brand lettuce, the crispier. Maya, do any of your kids wanna do, like, open their mouths and make sounds that sound like music? They're very, they all seem to wanna be filmmakers, so that's definitely happening. Because your partner is Paul Thomas Anderson. All of the above, he's all of those things. And you know, and they have iMovie, so they make a lot of movies
贝特曼牌生菜，更酥脆。玛雅，你的孩子有谁想，比如，张开嘴发出听起来像音乐的声音吗？他们看起来都想成为电影制作人，所以这肯定会发生。因为你的伴侣是保罗·托马斯·安德森。以上皆是，他就是所有那些东西。而且你知道，他们有iMovie，所以他们制作了很多电影
all the time, which is pretty damn cute. All four of them. Oh, that's great. Truly? Mm-hmm. When Archie was born, the night he was born, it was a Saturday night, and of course, Amy didn't make the show that night.
一直都在做，这真的很可爱。四个都是。哦，那太棒了。真的吗？嗯哼。阿奇出生时，他出生的那天晚上，是个周六晚上，当然，艾米那天没赶上节目。
We were supposed to do a Bronx beat that night. You're supposed to do a... You're talking about Amy Poehler from Saturday Night Live is your ex-wife. Don't forget, well, your OB died. Our OB died the day before, so the day that... Wait, what? So it was the first time Ham was hosting SNL, do you remember?
我们那天晚上本来要做“Bronx Beat”。你本来要做一个……你在说《周六夜现场》的艾米·波勒是你前妻。别忘了，嗯，你的产科医生死了。我们的产科医生前一天死了，所以那天……等等，什么？所以那是哈姆第一次主持SNL，你记得吗？
So Ham was hosting and I was... John Ham. ...going to pick up Amy, they were shooting... John Ham, Sean... Thanks, Sean. Sean is like an audio Chiron. Well, and you know what? And here's the thing.
所以哈姆在主持，我当时……乔恩·哈姆。……去接艾米，他们在拍摄……乔恩·哈姆，肖恩……谢谢，肖恩。肖恩就像个音频提词器。嗯，你知道吗？还有一件事。
By the way, I have to jump in. So my sister and all her friends live in Wisconsin and they listen to these podcasts and she's like, I don't know what they're talking about half the time. They're throwing about names. So that's why I'm plugging in all these names because they don't- You know what my advice to your sister is?
顺便说一句，我得插一句。所以我的姐姐和她所有的朋友住在威斯康星州，她们听这些播客，她说，她们有一半时间不知道他们在说什么。他们在抛出名字。所以这就是为什么我插入所有这些名字，因为她们不——你知道我对你姐姐的建议是什么吗？
Move, okay? So anyway, that's fair enough. That's fair enough. So Jon Hamm, first time he's hosting. So we go and we're supposed to go to this doctor's appointment and the OB dies. He dies that day. Are you being serious? That's crazy. That's what, yeah, so he was old.
搬家，好吗？所以无论如何，这很公平。这很公平。所以乔恩·哈姆，第一次主持。所以我们去了，我们本来要去参加这个医生预约，然后产科医生死了。他那天死了。你是认真的吗？那太疯狂了。这就是，是的，所以他很老了。
He was old. He was very old. Why was she seeing a guy on his death's doorstep? Did she get a deal on him or something like that? You feel like you get an OB-GYN that's got a few more years left. Vibrant, yeah. So anyways, so we go. Sometimes you want the best, you go to the quality. This guy had delivered, this is not a bit,
他很老了。他非常老。为什么她要看一个快死的人？她是在他身上得到了什么优惠还是什么的？你觉得你会找一个还有几年寿命的产科医生。充满活力，是的。所以无论如何，所以我们去了。有时你想要最好的，你追求质量。这个家伙接生过，这不是段子，
the big thing was he had delivered Sophia Lorenz' baby. Oh my God. Back in the day, whatever. And we were like, that was great in like 1950. Beautiful baby, that was a beautiful baby. What a baby. But then apparently he forgot about it. But anyway, look.
最重要的是他给索菲亚·罗兰接生过孩子。哦天哪。在那个年代，什么的。我们当时就像，那在1950年左右很棒。漂亮的婴儿，那是个漂亮的婴儿。多好的婴儿。但后来显然他忘了。但无论如何，看。
So anyway, we go in and Archie is born and we turn on the show that night and he's a couple hours old and Maya sang a song. Oh yeah, Keenan and I sang a song for little baby Archie. Really, live? Yeah. Oh, that's so nice. Wow.
所以无论如何，我们进去了，阿奇出生了，我们那天晚上打开节目，他才几个小时大，玛雅唱了一首歌。哦是的，基南和我为小阿奇唱了一首歌。真的，现场？是的。哦，那太好了。哇。
I'm nice sometimes, Sean, I really am. Well, that's not coming through. Uh oh, sorry Wisconsin. You are the nicest, I love you to death, you know that. I know, I love you too. I wanna ask you some more stuff, but can I go to SNL, which I know you're probably sick of talking about,
我有时很友善，肖恩，我真的是。嗯，那没表现出来。呃哦，抱歉威斯康星州。你是最友善的，我爱你爱得要死，你知道的。我知道，我也爱你。我想再问你一些事情，但我能去SNL吗，我知道你可能厌倦谈论它了，
or maybe you're not, but I. I'm cool. I hosted your first year of SNL. I was a host during your first year. Oh, I remember. And even then, I was SNL. I was a host during your first year. Oh, I remember. And even then I was like, as I was hosting, I was like, who is this master of comedy, this girl, who I'm falling in love with so quickly
或者也许你没有，但我。我很酷。我主持了你第一年的SNL。我在你第一年时是主持人。哦，我记得。即使在那时，我是SNL。我在你第一年时是主持人。哦，我记得。即使在那时，我就像，当我主持时，我就像，这个喜剧大师是谁，这个女孩，我爱上得如此之快
without as much as a date? I remember the Facts of Life sketch so well that you put up, and it was, Mrs. Garrett stuck a carrot up her butt and that's why her hair so red keeps singing these are the facts of life. I can't believe you remember that. That is insane.
甚至没约过会？我记得你做的那个《生活的事实》小品太清楚了，那是，加勒特太太把胡萝卜塞进屁股里，这就是为什么她的头发那么红，一直唱着“这就是生活的事实”。我不敢相信你还记得那个。那太疯狂了。
Because I couldn't stop singing it afterwards. Mrs. Garrett stuck a carrot up her butt in this wild, here's old Red keeps singing. But it's got, it's got, wait, it's got, wait, it's got a bunch of verses. These are the facts of life. These are the facts of life. It was, it was, um. Who wrote that lyric?
因为我之后无法停止唱它。加勒特太太把胡萝卜塞进屁股里，在这个狂野的，这是老红一直唱着。但它有，它有，等等，它有，等等，它有几段歌词。这就是生活的事实。这就是生活的事实。它是，它是，嗯。谁写的歌词？
He did. Me and Raina got super stoned, and Raina's is a friend of mine and wrote this entire song called the facts of Life and it went through rain is a friend of Sean's who's a cook and who's a very good friend of Sean. Sorry. Keep going That's for Wisconsin All right, so wait so back to SNL So when you were there and I know everybody asked this, but for anybody who's not, who's never been part of the institution of comedy, you know,
他写的。我和雷娜吸得超级嗨，雷娜是我朋友，写了这整首叫《生活的事实》的歌，它经过了雷娜是肖恩的朋友，是个厨师，也是肖恩很好的朋友。抱歉。继续。那是给威斯康星州的。好吧，所以等等，回到SNL。所以当你在那里时，我知道每个人都问这个，但对于任何不是，从来没有成为喜剧机构一部分的人，你知道，
that creates legends like you are now, and yes you are, thank you Sean, you're welcome, Maya. No one said anything. Everyone always asked. I just wanna cut him off again, because I feel like he might land the plane at some point during the fucking podcast. But I did wanna say, Maya, you are comedy royalty to me.
它创造了像你现在这样的传奇，是的，你是，谢谢肖恩，不客气，玛雅。没人说什么。每个人总是问。我只是想再次打断他，因为我觉得他可能会在播客的某个时候降落飞机。但我确实想说，玛雅，对我来说你是喜剧界的皇室成员。
And if anyone was listening to anything I've said over the last 20 years, I reference you all the time when we talk about... Everybody does. A certain level of sophistication in comedy, I will say, like Maya Rudolph. And people go, oh, I get it. I swear to God. If you're only saying this for me being here today, I do appreciate it.
如果有人听过我过去20年说的任何话，我总是提到你，当我们谈论……每个人都这样。某种程度的喜剧复杂性，我会说，像玛雅·鲁道夫。人们会说，哦，我明白了。我发誓。如果你今天只是因为我在这里才这么说，我很感激。
It's so true, Maya, you know how I feel. You are one of the comedy legends of history for true. People get it, it's a very efficient, economical way to say, oh you would like some smart laughs. Got it. Wow, that's a pretty large compliment, thank you, my friend. It is absolutely true.
这是真的，玛雅，你知道我的感受。你是历史上真正的喜剧传奇之一。人们明白了，这是一种非常高效、经济的方式来说，哦，你想要一些聪明的笑声。明白了。哇，这真是个很大的赞美，谢谢你，我的朋友。这绝对是真的。
But I think that what Jason's getting to, not only are you known for that, but I will say that as somebody who has worked with you a bunch over the years, and Sean can attest to this too, and the three of us did work together as well, there is nobody who's quicker or faster or better in the moment and can eke out, make anything funny, even if the scene is terrible and you wanna throw it out
但我认为杰森要说的是，你不仅以那个闻名，而且我要说，作为多年来和你合作过很多次的人，肖恩也可以证明这一点，我们三个也确实一起工作过，没有人比你更快、更敏捷或在当下更好，能挤出，让任何事情变得有趣，即使场景很糟糕，你想把它扔掉
and then find it in the trash and throw it out again because it's so bad. You have the ability to make every, you bring just, you always bring the element, and this is I think the real, the sort of the trademark of something is really funny, you always bring in the element of surprise. I never know what you're gonna do and it's so every time it's so awesome I always feel yeah, it's exciting doing a scene with you
然后从垃圾桶里找出来再扔掉，因为它太糟糕了。你有能力让每一个，你带来只是，你总是带来惊喜的元素。我从来不知道你会做什么，每次都太棒了。我总是觉得，是的，和你一起演戏很令人兴奋。
You know that is why getting old is great because we all remember things a lot less than what really happened So your memories all of your memories of our time together are so vague. The humility and the deflection. I love it. This is part of the intelligence. It's nice, but honestly it is nice to appreciate. I will get honest for a moment. It's nice to appreciate each other as we age. It's nice to have had fun together because my thing, once I started having kids and having
你知道这就是为什么变老很棒，因为我们都记得事情比实际发生的少得多。所以你的记忆，你所有关于我们在一起时光的记忆都如此模糊。谦逊和转移。我喜欢它。这是智慧的一部分。这很好，但老实说，互相欣赏随着年龄增长是很好的。很高兴我们一起玩得很开心，因为我的事，一旦我开始生孩子，不得不去工作，
to go to work, I realized like, oh, I have to actually like what I'm doing today or I'm gonna want to kill myself. Because it's so depressing when you hate your job and you've left your beautiful babies at home. So all the time that I've spent with you guys and out in the world and doing things, I cherish those times because all I did was laugh my ass off. So hard.
我意识到，哦，我必须真正喜欢我今天做的事情，否则我会想自杀。因为当你讨厌你的工作，又把可爱的孩子留在家里时，这太令人沮丧了。所以我和你们在一起，在世界上做事情的所有时间，我珍惜那些时光，因为我所做的就是笑得前仰后合。太厉害了。
I remember there's this one scene that you and I were in in the show called Up All Night that Will was also in with Christina Applegate. Sure. And those are my reference points, Will. So what network was it on? Just people don't know. This was about the Coke addicts, right?
我记得有一个场景，你和我都在那个叫《整夜难眠》的节目里，威尔也在里面，还有克里斯蒂娜·艾伯盖特。当然。那些是我的参考点，威尔。所以它在哪个频道播？只是人们不知道。这是关于可卡因瘾君子的，对吧？
What network was it on? Just people don't know. This was about the Coke addicts, right? No, it wasn't. It wasn't. So, and Maya, there was this scene where it wasn't quite there yet with just the rehearsal and the writing and us acting. And we just were trying to-
它在哪个频道播？只是人们不知道。这是关于可卡因瘾君子的，对吧？不，不是。不是。所以，玛雅，有一个场景，在排练和写作以及我们表演时，它还没完全到位。我们只是在试着——
And I kept saying, is it in? Yeah, right, and I said, I said, I said if you can't feel it by now, it's never gonna be. And we crafted the scene in such a way that we finally got it there. and then when we shot it, you made, like to Will's point, you made it so funny, I couldn't breathe laughing, and it was in a house.
我一直说，它进去了吗？是的，没错，我说，我说，我说如果你现在还感觉不到，它永远也不会有了。我们以这样一种方式精心制作了这个场景，我们终于让它到位了。然后当我们拍摄它时，你做了，就像威尔说的，你让它变得如此有趣，我笑得喘不过气来，而且是在房子里。
Oh, was it that Halloween thing where we were supposed to be dead or something? We were pretending to, yeah. Oh, God, I laughed so hard. But okay, so here's the thing, now you've accomplished something that. God, you really did your homework, Sean, what's happening? This is the obligation of the host, of the person who invites the guest.
哦，是那个万圣节的事情吗，我们本来应该死了还是什么的？我们假装，是的。哦，天哪，我笑得太厉害了。但好吧，所以这是事情，现在你完成了一些事情。天哪，你真的做了功课，肖恩，发生了什么？这是主持人的义务，邀请嘉宾的人的义务。
They need to be the adult. They need to have the questions. And then the other two idiots get to just throw bombs from the sidelines. I've never seen this side of you, Sean. Well, it's comforting, isn't it? It's welcome. But like to your point... If you tighten it up, it is. So... Okay, listen. listen to me.
他们需要成为成年人。他们需要有问题。然后另外两个白痴就可以从场边扔炸弹。我从来没见过你这一面，肖恩。嗯，这很令人欣慰，不是吗？这很受欢迎。但就像你说的……如果你把它收紧，它就是。所以……好吧，听着。听我说。
Now you've accomplished something, and now I'm gonna compliment these other two jerks. You've accomplished something that even Jason will have accomplished, and I wanted to talk about this. You all came onto the scene as actors who excel in comedy, and that's kind of what made you famous in the world, and you all have expanded your repertoire and kind of like crushing the dramatic work as well.
现在你完成了一些事情，现在我要赞美另外两个混蛋。你完成了一些连杰森也会完成的事情，我想谈谈这个。你们都是作为擅长喜剧的演员进入这个圈子的，这就是让你们在世界上出名的原因，你们都扩展了你们的剧目，并且在戏剧作品上也表现出色。
Like I even told Jason on Ozark, it's the best work I've ever seen him do. He's incredible on the show. And when he cries, I cry. Very nice of you, thank you. Look, his face hasn't changed. But you both excelled at the drama work too, and I know that's hard to accomplish, but what's really hard to accomplish, and you guys have all done it,
就像我甚至告诉杰森在《黑钱胜地》里，这是我见过他做的最好的工作。他在节目里令人难以置信。当他哭时，我也哭。你太好了，谢谢。看，他的脸没变。但你们两个在戏剧作品上也表现出色，我知道这很难完成，但真正难完成的是，你们都做到了，
which is to hold on to a sense of where you came from and acknowledging your comedic roots. Because I feel that a lot of people who are famous because of comedy immediately take themselves too seriously and then lose themselves in the journey to prove that they're more than that and in doing so sometimes they fail. I mean, do you know what I mean? I think so. I was guilty of that first season of Ozark.
那就是保持对你来自哪里的感觉，并承认你的喜剧根源。因为我觉得很多因为喜剧而出名的人立刻把自己看得太重，然后在证明他们不仅仅是那样的人的过程中迷失了自己，这样做有时他们会失败。我的意思是，你知道我的意思吗？我想是的。我在《黑钱胜地》第一季时犯了那个错误。
I had the head writer, show runner cut out all the comedy that he put, it wasn't a ton of comedy, but there were some things that were, and I was like, I was so like, people have to know that this is a drama, you know, and they're gonna think that it's a comedy, because I'm to know that this is a drama, they're gonna think that it's a comedy, because I'm in it. It is a drama.
我让首席编剧、剧集主管删掉了他放进去的所有喜剧，虽然喜剧不多，但有一些东西是，我当时就像，我非常像，人们必须知道这是一部戏剧，你知道，他们会认为这是一部喜剧，因为我……人们必须知道这是一部戏剧，他们会认为这是一部喜剧，因为我在里面。这是一部戏剧。
Well, exactly, but like a great writer does, throws in moments of levity to, and so I got less precious about that in the second season, and people really liked that about his writing and the third season as well. And that was the second season is when they stopped calling you precious on set, right? Yep, yeah, that was the end of that. Figured out what was causing it and put an end to it.
嗯，完全正确，但就像伟大的作家所做的那样，加入轻松的时刻来，所以我对第二季的那个就不那么珍视了，人们真的很喜欢他写作中的那一点，第三季也是。那是第二季，他们停止在片场叫你“珍贵”的时候，对吧？是的，是的，那是结束了。弄清楚了是什么导致的，并结束了它。
I was going to say, I mean, you guys all know, I mean, comedy is just infinitely more difficult than drama over time. To be consistently, you know, funny, it's much harder than... Well, dying is easy, comedy is hard. I mean, I have to teach them all these old things. Did you just come up with that? Holy shit. I mean I have to teach them all these Shit I mean You know
我本来想说，我的意思是，你们都知道，我的意思是，随着时间的推移，喜剧比戏剧要困难得多。要始终如一地，你知道，有趣，比……嗯，死亡很容易，喜剧很难。我的意思是，我必须教他们所有这些老东西。你刚想出那个吗？该死。我的意思是，我必须教他们所有这些。该死，我的意思是，你知道。
Real write it down real quick. You're sitting at a desk. Oh, I did that's why I just read it off my page The truth is that yeah, what I mean what you're saying. Well is what I feel is like, you know at a certain point you realize how They're also the comedy and the dramas few and far between and you realize how, also the comedy and the drama is few and far between and you realize how serious and depressed you really are as a comedian internally and then like it's all kind of part and parcel the same thing so all the little funny bits make the serious stuff real and it's all kind of. I like that movie you did with Krasinski
真的，快记下来。你正坐在书桌前。哦，我确实记了，所以我才刚从纸上读出来。事实是，是的，我的意思是，你所说的，就是我的感受，你知道，在某个时刻你会意识到，喜剧和正剧其实并不遥远，你会意识到，喜剧和正剧其实并不遥远，你会意识到，作为一个喜剧演员，你在内心深处是多么严肃和压抑，然后这一切其实都是同一件事的一部分，所以那些小小的搞笑片段让严肃的内容变得真实，这一切都是……我喜欢你和克拉辛斯基拍的那部电影。
where you guys were, it was funny but you also had dramatic moments, with Krasinski where you guys were it was funny but also dramatic moments John Krasinski from the office Jesus he was on the office he was on the office Wisconsin and Sam Mendes directed yeah and Sam Mendes directed and you guys that was a great and I I said this when we made our little show flake that not a lot of people saw that was on Netflix but I used to say people say is that a comedy drama I'm like I don't know when I wake up in the morning you don't go, today's gonna be a comedy day. Or today's gonna be a drama day. I wanted it to feel like a representation
你们在一起的时候，很有趣，但也有戏剧性的时刻，和克拉辛斯基在一起的时候，你们在一起的时候，很有趣，但也有戏剧性的时刻，来自《办公室》的约翰·克拉辛斯基，天哪，他演过《办公室》，他演过《办公室》，威斯康星，还有萨姆·门德斯导演，是的，萨姆·门德斯导演，你们那部戏很棒，我在制作我们那个小节目《Flaked》时说过，虽然没多少人看，是在Netflix上播的，但我常说，人们问那是喜剧还是正剧？我说我不知道，当你早上醒来时，你不会说，今天要是喜剧日，或者今天要是正剧日。我希望它能像一种生活体验的写照。
of what a life experience is. I mean, other than like Mel Brooks' house, I don't know that most comedy households are always funny, right? No. They're probably real quiet. They're probably really dark. Yeah, for sure.
我的意思是，除了像梅尔·布鲁克斯家那样，我不知道大多数喜剧演员的家庭是否总是那么有趣，对吧？不。他们可能很安静。他们可能真的很阴郁。是的，肯定的。
Now, Maya, with all the years of experience that you have and the clear understanding, obviously, of the nuance of comedy as well as drama, do you have any desire to write anything long form or direct anything long form and kind of be the person that navigates all that stuff? Directing, no. Directing, I absolutely don't ever want to do.
那么，玛雅，凭借你多年的经验，以及对喜剧和正剧细微差别的清晰理解，你是否有意愿去创作或执导任何长篇作品，并成为那个掌控全局的人？执导，不。执导，我绝对不想做。
And I think it's the amount of responsibility that's required that makes me feel like itchy and hot. Like knowing that I have to make sure you've got this covered. It's like being the host of a party and making sure everybody's happy. I don't think that's in my nature, and I'm okay with that.
我认为正是那种所需的责任感让我感到焦虑和烦躁。就像知道我必须确保一切都在掌控之中。这就像是派对的主人，要确保每个人都开心。我觉得这不符合我的天性，我对此没意见。
That's why I live with a director. I don't wanna be one. But I honestly enjoy the produce serial side of giving my opinion, putting my time in. I mean, I feel like I'm gonna be a forever writer in the way that I sort of just like haphazardly became a writer at SNL because they just make you write. You don't have a choice and no one really says, hey, you're a writer now. You're just like, they just make you write. You don't have a choice. And no one really says, hey, you're a writer now.
这就是为什么我和一位导演住在一起。我不想成为导演。但我真心享受制片方面的工作，发表我的意见，投入我的时间。我的意思是，我觉得我会永远做一个编剧，就像我在《周六夜现场》时那样，我是偶然成为编剧的，因为他们强迫你写。你没得选，也没人真的会说，嘿，你现在是编剧了。你只是……他们强迫你写。你没得选。也没人真的会说，嘿，你现在是编剧了。
You're just like, I'm writing my sketches. I don't have a choice. And it's really the only way to survive. So I think I'll continue to create what I do. But the directing part, I like to I like to sit down and eat my lunch. You know, I don't like to be a guest at the party, not hosted. Yeah, it's so stressful. And I love when people love doing it, and I love to be a part of that,
你只是觉得，我在写我的小品。我没得选。这真的是生存的唯一方式。所以我认为我会继续创作我所做的事情。但导演的部分，我喜欢……我喜欢坐下来吃午饭。你知道，我不喜欢做派对的客人，而不是主人。是的，压力太大了。我喜欢那些热爱导演工作的人，我也喜欢参与其中，
but I feel like there was a point in my life where I thought like, I'm gonna do this, and I'm gonna do that. And then once I started realizing, I don't, I'm not good at everything, and that's okay. I'm sort of like, yeah, there's no shame in that game. My recollection of Maya on a boat night is this like, we'd be shooting all day and be like, lunch,
但我感觉我生命中曾有一个阶段，我想过，我要做这个，我要做那个。然后当我开始意识到，我并不是什么都擅长，那也没关系。我有点像，是的，这没什么好丢人的。我对玛雅在船上过夜的记忆是这样的，我们整天都在拍摄，然后说，午餐，
and then her dressing room is next to mine, and then like knock on the door and be like, are we still shooting that scene after lunch? I mean, are we done with it? I'd be feeling the same way. I'd be like, I don't know. We both had little kids at all. I don't know.
然后她的化妆间就在我隔壁，然后敲门说，午餐后我们还要拍那场戏吗？我的意思是，我们拍完了吗？我当时也有同样的感觉。我会说，我不知道。我们俩当时都有小孩。我不知道。
I was nursing, remember? I was nursing at the same way. I'd be like, I don't know. We both had little kids at home. I don't know. I was nursing. Remember I was nursing? Like, right, like the baby was in the room. I was pumping and I was sweating all the time. Was that Jack who was just born? It was Jack, yeah. He just turned nine. I want to ask you a serious question. I don't know if I'm going to get through it with my co-host, but here we go. Okay, hang on. Let me get the stopwatch and go.
我在哺乳，记得吗？我在哺乳，当时也有同样的感觉。我会说，我不知道。我们俩当时家里都有小孩。我不知道。我在哺乳。记得吗，我在哺乳？就像，对，宝宝就在房间里。我一直在挤奶，一直在出汗。那是刚出生的杰克吗？是杰克，是的。他刚满九岁。我想问你一个严肃的问题。我不知道我能不能在我的联合主持人在场的情况下问出来，但我们要开始了。好吧，等等。让我拿秒表开始。
Your mom so sadly passed away when you were younger. I think you were six, seven, eight years old, something like that. In the wheelhouse, yes. Yeah, in that wheelhouse. And so, and you're such an incredible mom, as I've seen firsthand, and it always seems like your children comes first,
你妈妈在你很小的时候不幸去世了。我想你当时六、七、八岁左右，差不多那个年纪。在那个范围内，是的。是的，在那个范围内。所以，你是一位如此出色的母亲，我亲眼所见，而且看起来你的孩子们总是第一位的，
which is the correct thing to do. Thank you. And before anything else. And you're always present, and it's what every kid wants but does any part of you when you are starting to have kids like and it's it's did you have a one of those real human fears of oh my god what if what happened to me happens to my children and i'm not around is that gonna happen and oh i'm still not sure that i'm doing this correctly and i get weirded out all the time that I'm 48 and my mom was only 31 when she died and I'm like,
这是正确的做法。谢谢。在任何事情之前。而且你总是陪伴在身边，这是每个孩子都想要的，但当你开始有孩子时，有没有哪一部分的你，会有那种真正的人类恐惧，比如，天哪，如果发生在我身上的事发生在我孩子身上怎么办？如果我不在了怎么办？会发生那种事吗？而且我还是不确定我是否做得对，我总是觉得很奇怪，我已经48岁了，而我妈妈去世时才31岁，我就想，
now what? How did I get to be older than my mother? It's so crazy. I don't know how the hell we're all adults to begin with, let alone responsible for other people and in relationships and families, it's crazy. But I. What's your perfect ratio. My perfect mate. Your perfect ratio of work to parenting. Like what are you doing today aside from this? Like do you.
现在怎么办？我是怎么活得比我妈妈还大的？这太疯狂了。我不知道我们到底是怎么长成大人的，更不用说还要对其他人负责，还要处理人际关系和家庭，这太疯狂了。但我。你工作与育儿的完美比例是多少？你今天除了这个还做什么？比如你……
That's a great question. I appreciate that question. I'm gonna do a little voiceover work later on this afternoon. Who are you working for? Working for a wonderful production called Bless the Hearts by our friend Emily Spivey. Oh, bless the hearts. I love that. I love Emily Spivey.
这是个好问题。我很欣赏这个问题。我今天下午晚些时候要做一点配音工作。你为谁工作？为一部很棒的作品《Bless the Hearts》工作，是我们朋友艾米丽·斯派维做的。哦，《Bless the Hearts》。我喜欢那个。我喜欢艾米丽·斯派维。
Oh, bless the hearts. I'll sit up the night with. Are they looking for any new characters or? God, that's good. That's really good. It was sexy but also a little bit scary. Oh, this guy. And a little bit sad.
哦，《Bless the Hearts》。我会熬夜陪着。他们在找新角色吗？天哪，那太棒了。真的太棒了。它很性感，但也有一点点可怕。哦，这家伙。还有一点点悲伤。
Like a little bit like... Well, you know what? Because he's had a few, even though it's Wednesday. He said he wouldn't, but he did. I thought he was constipated. No, he had a few. He sounds like he needs water. When ain't nobody was looking, he had a few.
就像有一点点……嗯，你知道吗？因为他喝了几杯，尽管今天是周三。他说他不会喝的，但他喝了。我以为他便秘了。不，他喝了几杯。他听起来需要喝水。当没人注意的时候，他喝了几杯。
Or he's a self-asphyxiator there in the jackshack. Oh boy. You know what's funny? I did write, in the time that we've been on this, I did write a theme song for the jackshack and it's called, Jackshack, shakin' it up. Jackshack, you can shack it.
或者他在“杰克小屋”里自我窒息。天哪。你知道什么很有趣吗？我确实写了，在我们录制这段时间里，我确实为“杰克小屋”写了一首主题曲，它叫《杰克小屋，摇起来》。杰克小屋，你可以摇动它。
Jackshack, shakin' it up. Jackshack, shakin' it up, Jack, Jack, Jackin' it up, Jack. Get your Jack on. I love the end, I love the end. Jackin' it up, Jack. I wish we had an animated portion of this show. It'd be so good. Jack, Jack.
杰克小屋，摇起来。杰克小屋，摇起来，杰克，杰克，摇起来，杰克。开始你的杰克时间。我喜欢结尾，我喜欢结尾。摇起来，杰克。我希望我们节目有个动画部分。那会很棒。杰克，杰克。
Maya used to do this character, we were gonna do a video and I was gonna be this French. Oh, Pop the Cork. Pop the Cork and I was DJ Metro, it's a French rapper. And it's just Maya, and she's in just like, she's in Saint Tropez, and she's in Italy. I like to celebrate. Pop the Cork.
玛雅以前常演这个角色，我们本来要拍个视频，我要演这个法国人。哦，Pop the Cork。Pop the Cork，我是DJ Metro，是个法国说唱歌手。然后就是玛雅，她在圣特罗佩，她在意大利。我喜欢庆祝。Pop the Cork。
Pop the Cork. We would just say like, London. Pop the Cork, Dubai. Pop the Crika, Israel. I wanna see you doing all these characters every week again, damn it. I should answer your question because you bring something up,
Pop the Cork。我们只会说，伦敦。Pop the Cork，迪拜。Pop the Crika，以色列。我真想再看到你每周都演这些角色，该死。我应该回答你的问题，因为你提到了，
which is that I do, every once in a while I go, God, I should do that show, or I should, when we were asking about creating and stuff, like, oh yeah, I should create this show, and then I'm like, what am I saying? Then I'll never be home. I can't do that. But I'm lucky enough to have a lot of talented friends
那就是，我确实，偶尔我会想，天哪，我应该做那个节目，或者我应该，当我们问到关于创作之类的事情时，比如，哦对，我应该创作这个节目，然后我就想，我在说什么？那我永远都回不了家了。我做不到。但我很幸运有很多有才华的朋友，
and I'll do like a little bit here and a little bit there and a little bit. And that's plenty for you. That's enough for you. It's plenty. Sometimes I spread myself too thin and then everyone's all say, no, now I'm ready to get back in the saddle and do it.
我会在这里做一点，在那里做一点。这对你来说就足够了。这对你来说足够了。足够了。有时我把自己搞得太累了，然后每个人都说，不，现在我准备好重整旗鼓去做了。
But I also like to go home sometimes. Have you been courageous enough to play with the idea of an empty nest at some point, sometime deep, deep in the future? I say that because I have, and it just, as much as I am, I love to be out and working. I love my kids. I love that they are here, and I think I'm going to be a mess when they go to college. For sure. You have that times too, right? Because I got two kids, I love that they are here, and I think I'm gonna be a mess when they go to college. You have that times two, right? Because I got two kids, you got four.
但我有时也喜欢回家。你是否有足够的勇气去尝试空巢期的想法，在遥远的未来某个时候？我这么说是因为我有过，而且，尽管我喜欢外出工作。我爱我的孩子们。我喜欢他们在这里，我想当他们上大学时我会崩溃的。肯定的。你也有过那种时候，对吧？因为我有两个孩子，我喜欢他们在这里，我想当他们上大学时我会崩溃的。你也有过那种时候，对吧？因为我有两个孩子，你有四个。
Yeah, and you know that when one of the kids isn't home and they're at a friend's house or something, you feel like, there's no one here, the house is so quiet, and it's such a strange, yeah, I don't know. I don't know what I'm gonna do, but maybe that's a good time to move back to New York and start all over again. Yeah, there you go.
是的，你知道当其中一个孩子不在家，去朋友家什么的，你会觉得，这里没人，房子太安静了，这真是一种奇怪的感觉，是的，我不知道。我不知道我会做什么，但也许那是搬回纽约重新开始的好时机。是的，就是这样。
Both see Puppetry of the Penis with Ali and. Yeah, just do some sort of a sequel to Puppetry of the Penis. What would that be called? Huh. I wanna go back to the question I had about. We'll come back on that. 30 minutes ago.
都看过阿里和……的《阴茎木偶戏》。是的，就做某种《阴茎木偶戏》的续集。那叫什么名字？嗯。我想回到我刚才问的问题。我们稍后再谈那个。30分钟前。
Yeah, Sean, definitely tee up another real question. Go ahead, Sean. What's number two? I wanna know because I wanna know these things. I know you do, and you know what, by the way? Good for you. Thanks, guys. I know, it's very responsible.
是的，肖恩，一定要再准备一个真正的问题。继续吧，肖恩。第二个是什么？我想知道，因为我想了解这些事情。我知道你想，顺便说一句，做得好。谢谢，伙计们。我知道，这非常有责任感。
I feel like you brought me in and you're like, I have to ask her real questions or she's good. Yeah, otherwise it's like, they're just bits which I love. I don't care, you don't have to ask me anything real. Listen, you can ask me anything you want. I love it, and so I wanna know how you feel about me. No, I wanna know. So, I wanna know, like,
我觉得你把我带进来，然后你就像，我必须问她真正的问题，否则她会……是的，不然就像，那只是些我喜欢的片段。我不在乎，你不需要问我任何真实的问题。听着，你可以问我任何你想问的。我喜欢，所以我想知道你对我感觉如何。不，我想知道。所以，我想知道，比如，
cause way back 30 minutes ago when I was talking about Saturday Night Live and how you've helped create that institution that it is. Everybody wants to know what was it like getting the gig that you always dreamed of getting? Like, what was it like the first week? Is it like the first week of school? And were you nervous? And like like how did you navigate around that?
因为30分钟前当我谈到《周六夜现场》以及你是如何帮助创造那个机构时。每个人都想知道，得到你一直梦想得到的工作是什么感觉？比如，第一周是什么感觉？就像开学第一周吗？你紧张吗？你是怎么应对的？
That was crazy because I came in at the end of the 25th season and I had this really lame situation where I listened to like a bad manager. I was so young and she said don't audition the new contracts are really binding and I went oh okay. I a fucking idiot. And so I did an audition, and then long story short, I was lucky enough that they asked me to come and do the last three shows. So it was more like trial by fire,
那太疯狂了，因为我是第25季结束时进来的，我当时有个非常糟糕的情况，我听信了一个糟糕的经纪人。我当时太年轻了，她说不要试镜，新合同非常有约束力，我就想，哦，好吧。我真是个白痴。所以我试镜了，长话短说，我很幸运，他们让我来演最后三集。所以更像是火中取栗，
but it was the end of the season, so everyone knew each other already. It was like joining a school year with three weeks left. So like I didn't know anybody, and everybody knew where to sit, and the cafeteria kind of feeling. I could just felt really bad and scary. I didn't know that.
但那是季末，所以每个人都已经认识了。就像在学年还剩三周时加入一样。所以我谁也不认识，每个人都知道该坐在哪，那种食堂的感觉。我当时感觉真的很糟糕，很害怕。我不知道这一点。
You did not audition. No. So you were you a part of the writing staff and they wanted to put you on then on camera? No, it was really confusing. It wasn't clear. They brought me and Zach Galifianakis and I think it was Jerry Minor. I think we were the three people that they brought out for this three week trial period, but Zach and I didn't know what was going on. Zach said they brought, he had auditioned,
你没有试镜。没有。所以你是编剧组成员，他们想让你上镜？不，这真的很混乱。不清楚。他们带了我、扎克·加利凡纳基斯，我想还有杰瑞·迈纳。我想我们是他们带过来进行这三周试用期的三个人，但扎克和我不知道发生了什么。扎克说他们带了，他试镜了，
and then he said, like, they brought me out, but they were just auditioning him as a writer, and he was really like, I don't know what's happening. We were a little bit confused. Did Zach do the show? He wrote for three weeks. He and I shared an office and we were both like scratching our heads like... I didn't know that either. What are we doing?
然后他说，他们带我过来，但他们只是在面试他的编剧工作，他真的很困惑，不知道发生了什么。我们有点困惑。扎克演了那个节目吗？他写了三周。他和我在同一个办公室，我们俩都挠着头说……我也不知道这一点。我们在做什么？
See you assholes. It's good I ask questions like that. It is good. You know what Sean? Great question. Great question, Sean. Can you string two together? Well that seems like it's very difficult. I can't believe we've gotten to 30 minutes in and we haven't asked you whether you're excited or dreading the whole Kamala Harris for the next probably 12 years. Can I just say wouldn't that be a nice problem to have?
再见，你们这些混蛋。我问这样的问题很好。确实很好。你知道吗，肖恩？好问题。好问题，肖恩。你能连着问两个吗？嗯，那看起来很难。我不敢相信我们已经录了30分钟，还没问你对未来12年卡玛拉·哈里斯的看法是兴奋还是恐惧。我能说那会是一个很好的烦恼吗？
Oh God yes. Instead of this fucking shit pile of shit of shit mountain that we're living on? We just had her on the show. You did? Yeah. Literally the day before it was announced that she was on the ticket with Biden. She's pretty fantastic. She's awesome.
哦，天哪，是的。而不是我们现在生活的这堆该死的狗屎山？我们刚请她上过节目。你们请过？是的。就在宣布她和拜登搭档的前一天。她非常棒。她太棒了。
She's amazing. There's nothing there that isn't cool. It's like, hey, do you want to play a cool superhero? Like, yeah, sure. I'm good. Like, you know this, you know, you get to be Batman and it's fun. It's fun to like be a cool person. It's what am I going to do? It's kind of what I'm good. You know this, you get to be Batman, and it's fun. It's fun to be a cool person. What am I gonna do?
她很了不起。她身上没有什么是不可爱的。就像，嘿，你想演一个酷酷的超级英雄吗？就像，是的，当然。我很好。就像，你知道这个，你知道，你有机会成为蝙蝠侠，这很有趣。扮演一个酷酷的人很有趣。我该怎么办？这有点像我擅长的。你知道这个，你有机会成为蝙蝠侠，这很有趣。扮演一个酷酷的人很有趣。我该怎么办？
That's kinda what I'm known for, Batman. Oh, you're talking about Will? Yeah. But once the, as Will calls it, the hoax virus goes away, you're gonna have to fly back and forth to New York all the time. Are you going to be happy about that? That could get burdensome.
这就是我出名的原因，蝙蝠侠。哦，你在说威尔？是的。但一旦威尔所说的“骗局病毒”消失，你就得一直飞回纽约。你会为此感到高兴吗？那可能会变得很繁重。
I don't know. I think I'm a little bit in denial of what is happening in the world and what's going to happen. I mean, is there going to be a live show? It doesn't matter. You know what's going to happen. Let's not play this game. We both know what's going to happen. I like to play hard to get. You don't have to start wiggling when you say that, Maya. I still have my exercise tank on.
我不知道。我觉得我对世界上正在发生的事情以及将要发生的事情有点否认。我的意思是，会有现场直播吗？没关系。你知道会发生什么。我们别玩这个游戏了。我们都知道会发生什么。我喜欢欲擒故纵。你不需要在说这话时扭来扭去，玛雅。我还穿着我的运动背心呢。
I haven't exercised yet. I haven't showered. I haven't even showered yet. I'm so shy. I need to take a shower. You don't want any of this. Oh, oh. Do you guys want Chinese chicken salads for lunch?
我还没运动呢。我还没洗澡。我甚至还没洗澡。我太害羞了。我需要去洗澡。你不想看到这些。哦，哦。你们午餐想吃中式鸡肉沙拉吗？
Everybody? Everybody? Everybody's Chinese chicken salad Let's get chin chin. I want chin chin. Is chin chin still around? Yes, I get it all the time and it's so fattening. I call it double chins chin chin is still the best Just the Chinese chicken salad. I don't think I've ever had anything else But you know that the conversation that's happening right now is, so Maya will come and do this show. She'll come Saturday and then she'll come the next Saturday and so Maya will come. That's Will's attempt at Lorne Michaels impression, everybody.
每个人？每个人？每个人的中式鸡肉沙拉，我们去Chin Chin吧。我想吃Chin Chin。Chin Chin还在吗？是的，我经常吃，而且很容易发胖。我叫它双下巴，Chin Chin仍然是最好的。只是中式鸡肉沙拉。我想我没吃过别的。但你知道现在正在进行的对话是，玛雅会来做这个节目。她周六会来，然后下周六会来，所以玛雅会来。那是威尔模仿洛恩·迈克尔斯，大家。
Wisconsin. He says, Sean, they don't need to know. Not everybody needs to know everything. Lorne Michaels is my forever boss. I just decided the other day, like, he's my forever boss. He'll always be my boss. He'll be my friend. But no matter whether I ever work there again, like, he's my forever boss. He'll always be my boss. He'll be my friend, but no matter whether I ever work there again, he'll always be my forever boss.
威斯康星。他说，肖恩，他们不需要知道。不是每个人都需要知道一切。洛恩·迈克尔斯是我永远的老板。我前几天刚决定，他是我的老板。他永远是我的老板。他会是我的朋友。但无论我是否还会再在那里工作，他都是我永远的老板。他永远是我的老板。他会是我的朋友，但无论我是否还会再在那里工作，他永远是我永远的老板。
Mia, Mia Rudolph, you've been incredible. It's Mia Randolph. Here comes question three, get ready. No, this is no more questions. I was gonna wrap it up because I know you have kids to take care of. Oh, you mean diapers to change? Daddy!
玛雅，玛雅·鲁道夫，你太棒了。是玛雅·鲁道夫。第三个问题来了，准备好。不，没有更多问题了。我本来想结束的，因为我知道你有孩子要照顾。哦，你是说要换尿布？爸爸！
No, there's no more mean diapers to change? Daddy! There's no more in diapers right? You're done with diapers. I'm done with diapers. Yeah. So I can't thank you enough for being here and we love you very very very much. I love you very much. That was way too short. And even though we don't get to speak that often I think about you all the time. Really, like all the time? Yeah. Hey, hey guys. Hey, hey. That was so convincing.
不，没有更多要换尿布了？爸爸！没有更多要换尿布了，对吧？你不用换尿布了。我不用换尿布了。是的。所以我非常感谢你能来，我们非常非常非常爱你。我也非常爱你。这太短了。即使我们不能经常交谈，我也一直想着你。真的，一直想着？是的。嘿，嘿，伙计们。嘿，嘿。这太令人信服了。
That was so convincing. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, Sean. I do, I really do. I think about you all the time. You're always such a sweet little cookie for us.
这太令人信服了。是的。是的。是的。哦，肖恩。我确实，我真的。我一直想着你。你对我们来说一直是个可爱的小饼干。
Can you sing the Jack Shack, Sean, one more time? Is that our sign-off? Jack Shack, shakin' it up. Jack Shack, Sean, one more time. Is that our sign-off? Jack Shack, shakin' it up. Jack Shack, it's totally crispy. Jack Shack, 100%. 100% Jack Shack and then Jack! It's totally crispy. It's totally crispy.
你能再唱一遍杰克小屋吗，肖恩？那是我们的结束语吗？杰克小屋，摇起来。杰克小屋，肖恩，再来一次。那是我们的结束语吗？杰克小屋，摇起来。杰克小屋，完全酥脆。杰克小屋，100%。100%杰克小屋，然后杰克！它完全酥脆。它完全酥脆。
Think about it. It could be. Box of used socks sold separately. I was going to say there should be a sock sponsor to that. Maya, super, super nice of you to do this. That was really fun, you guys. It's nice to see you. This is one of those days where when I'm dying and I'm laying there, shriveled up, and then I'll think about today and I'm going to have a big smile on my face.
想一想。可能是。旧袜子盒另售。我本来想说应该有个袜子赞助商。玛雅，你做这个真是太好了。这真的很有趣，你们。很高兴见到你们。这是那种日子，当我快死的时候，躺在那里，干瘪了，我会想起今天，我的脸上会带着灿烂的笑容。
Likewise. Look at that. Love you, Maya. You're the best. You're the best! You're the best, man! You're the best! Thank you, Maya. Bye, guys. Enjoy the rest of your day.
同样。看看那个。爱你，玛雅。你是最棒的。你是最棒的！你是最棒的，伙计！你是最棒的！谢谢，玛雅。再见，伙计们。享受你们剩下的一天。
So nice to see you all. You too. Bye. See you later. Bye. Bye. Tongues Included. She winged that song and it's going to be my hat for the rest of the day. Jack Shack. We were working on, on, up all night, whatever, 10 years ago, and she said, uh, what did you do this week?
很高兴见到你们所有人。你也是。再见。回头见。再见。再见。包括舌头。她即兴唱了那首歌，这会成为我今天剩下的时间里的帽子。杰克小屋。我们十年前在录《Up All Night》什么的，她说，呃，你这周做了什么？
And I said, I spent most of the weekend in my Jack Shack. And she was so in that, she loved that idea. She thought it was the grossest expression and she used to bring it up all the time. She's like, how's your Jack Shack? Hey, is your Jack Shack taking this weekend? I need a place to live, bro. I got it on Airbnb now. Anyway, I love her, we love her, I'm so glad.
我说，我大部分周末都在我的杰克小屋里。她非常喜欢那个主意。她觉得这是最恶心的表达，她总是提起它。她说，你的杰克小屋怎么样？嘿，你的杰克小屋这个周末在忙吗？我需要个住的地方，兄弟。我现在把它放在Airbnb上了。总之，我爱她，我们爱她，我很高兴。
By the way, she's the kind of guest that we have on that we can just completely be ourselves and fuck around and it's so fun. She could guest host the show with us at any time because she's so funny and so, and we love her and know when she's got such an ease and comfort and she's just, everything about her is the fucking best. I love hanging out with Maya.
顺便说一句，她是那种我们可以完全做自己、胡闹的嘉宾，这太有趣了。她随时可以和我们一起主持节目，因为她太有趣了，而且我们爱她，知道她有一种轻松和舒适感，她的一切都是最棒的。我喜欢和玛雅在一起。
When I hosted Kimmel a couple years ago and- Oh, here we go, yep. And the ratings spiked. Point is this, I don't even know if sweeps are a thing but I know it was a big deal to Jimmy and it got him a new contract. And I don't even know how I started on this story. But the point is I needed a guest and I said, remember Jimmy's son was in the hospital and stuff
几年前我主持吉米·坎摩尔秀的时候——哦，开始了，是的。收视率飙升。重点是这个，我甚至不知道收视率调查是否重要，但我知道这对吉米来说是件大事，这让他签了新合同。我甚至不知道我是怎么开始讲这个故事的。但重点是我需要一个嘉宾，我说，记得吉米的孩子在医院什么的，
and last night when they were there and I needed a guest I was like, who can you count on in a pinch to come in and be funny and available? And Maya happened to drive by at that moment. No, and I called Maya because, yeah, because she's incredibly funny and quick, and she saved my ass. She made me look good.
昨晚他们在那儿，我需要一个嘉宾，我就想，在紧要关头你能指望谁来搞笑且有空？玛雅刚好在那一刻开车经过。不，我给玛雅打了电话，因为，是的，因为她非常有趣且反应快，她救了我的命。她让我看起来很棒。
Yeah, she's always, she's always that. Jason, have you ever worked with her? Yeah, she was on SNL the one time I hosted, way back when, but I would love to, and I was serious, I have talked about her a lot in anything that I have a half a say in. I've always wanted to. More and more and more.
是的，她总是，她总是那样。杰森，你和她合作过吗？是的，我主持的那次她也在《周六夜现场》，很久以前了，但我很想，我是认真的，在任何我有发言权的事情上，我都经常提到她。我一直想。越来越多。
I don't like what the kids are doing to her life and my ability to see her on camera more often, so I'd love to talk to her about that. Maybe finding another place for those kids to live would be best for me. Sure, yeah, that's a start. You should call Dave Becky and put a light of fire under his ass, you know?
我不喜欢孩子们对她生活的影响，以及我无法更频繁地在镜头前看到她，所以我很想和她谈谈。也许为那些孩子找个住的地方对我来说最好。当然，是的，这是个开始。你应该给戴夫·贝基打电话，让他加把劲，你知道吗？
Well, maybe Dave could babysit the kids and book her on a couple more things. That'd be great. Dave Becky is her manager. Uh-huh, thank you. Oh, Jesus. Thanks, Sean. Thanks, Sean.
嗯，也许戴夫可以帮她照看孩子，再给她预订几个节目。那太棒了。戴夫·贝基是她的经纪人。嗯哼，谢谢。哦，天哪。谢谢，肖恩。谢谢，肖恩。
That's my Wisconsin accent. Wisconsin. Hey, thanks. Hey guys, don't worry about it. Thank you. Thanks, Sean. That's my Wisconsin accent. Hey, thanks. Hey guys, don't worry about it. I got it all sorted out. I just heard Sean said that Dave Becky's her manager. Okay? Yeah, no, Sean just straightened it out. He straightened it out for us out here, okay? Don't worry, Dave. I guess he's some kind of Hollywood manager. Anyway, great guest. I love her, I love you guys. Bye! Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, Sean. Bye! It isn't! Oh.
那是我的威斯康星口音。威斯康星。嘿，谢谢。嘿，伙计们，别担心。谢谢。谢谢，肖恩。那是我的威斯康星口音。嘿，谢谢。嘿，伙计们，别担心。我全都搞定了。我刚听到肖恩说戴夫·贝基是她的经纪人。好吗？是的，不，肖恩刚刚澄清了。他为我们澄清了，好吗？别担心，戴夫。我想他是个好莱坞经纪人。总之，很棒的嘉宾。我爱她，我爱你们。再见！等等，等等，等等，等等，肖恩。再见！不是！哦。
Smart. Bless. Smart. Bless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。保佑。聪明。保佑。此剧集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。